2,000 years ago, Jesus said, I'm one of the ways, one of the truths, and one
possible life. If you want to come to the mother or the father through me, that's
cool. Go forth living according to whatever feels right to you.
Okay, you got me. Clearly, Jesus didn't say that.
In fact, he said quite the opposite.
If you look in the New Testament, you will find at least 100 verses that make it
clear that Jesus is the only way to God, the only way to experience an eternal
relationship with the Father. Truth is vitally important because eternity
is at stake. Now, philosophers use a term that seems fancy, but I think you'll find
it's kind of common sense, what's called the correspondence theory of truth.
And all this means is you have essentially a belief, this is an idea
you hold about the world. But then you have the world over here, this is reality.
Now, truth is not a belief. Truth is not reality.
Truth is when your belief matches up with reality.
That's what we mean by truth. Have you ever noticed how much you base your entire
life down to the details, the daily decisions on what you think is true?
What
if somebody says it's cold outside?
How do you check? Do you know whether that is true or whether that's false?
Well, you could look at a weather app and see what information it gives you, or you
could actually walk outside and you could see it for yourself.
If it is cold outside, then your belief is true.
If it's not cold outside, then the belief is false.
We do this with historical issues, such as the claim that Jesus rose from the grave,
and we do this with scientific matters, such as the claim or the belief that the
universe had a beginning. We actually do this on all sorts of issues.
We hold a variety of beliefs, and then we go see if the world is the way we take it
to be. If our beliefs match up, it's true.
If our beliefs don't, it's false.
But remember to keep this in mind.
Our beliefs don't create reality, but rather our beliefs should reflect reality.
You might be thinking, wait a minute.
When it comes to religious claims, can't you have your beliefs and I have mine?
Aren't your beliefs true for you?
But my religious beliefs are true for me.
Not too long ago, my father was speaking at a leadership event for about 400 high
school students. And in his session, my dad decided to walk out into the audience
and interact with the students. And he started by asking a simple question to a
student that was there. He said, do you think the Bible is true?
And the student jumped in. He goes, yes, I think the Bible is true.
My dad said, do you think it's scientifically and historically accurate in
everything it teaches that we properly understand?
The student looked back. He instantly said, of course.
And then my dad asked this simple question back.
He said, why?
And the student had no answer. In fact, my dad went around the room and not a single
student had a thoughtful answer to why he or she believed that the Bible is true.
Well, the session was done and my dad was walking towards the back of the
auditorium. And the student comes running up to my father.
He goes, Josh, Josh, I know the answer.
I know why the Bible is true. My dad said, great.
Why is the Bible true? He looks at my father and he says, The Bible is true because
I believe it. My dad said, wait a minute.
The Bible is true because you believe it.
What about a Quran and a Muslim who believes the Quran?
This student looked my dad right back in the eyes and he said, If a Muslim believes
the Quran is true, then the Quran is true for him.
Now, my dad gave back to the student a memorable and powerful response.
He said, here's the difference between me.
And you, you think the Bible is true because you believe it, but I believe the
Bible because I think it is true.
We see nothing is true or false because we believe it.
Our beliefs don't change reality.
But given how important truth is, let's hope that our beliefs match up
with reality.
We've been talking about why truth is important.
But let me share a story about my mom to help make this point really sink in.
So my mom has come a long ways with technology, but she honestly used to be afraid
of anything, technologically speaking.
In fact, when my mom gets something new with technology, she would read the
instructions letter by letter and follow it as best as she can.
Well, she got a computer. Up pops something that says, close all
windows.
Well, my mom decides to, and I think you see where this is going.
Get up from her chair, walk around the house and close all the windows.
And when she told this story, obviously a little bit embarrassed, we realized that
truth has consequences. In this case, embarrassment, confusion, but in many cases,
confusing truth can lead to devastating consequences.
But when we know truth, we're set free.
So we see a computer. It's created and designed to function a certain way.
When we use it according to its design, then we're set free.
We can accomplish it. We can accomplish things.
But when we don't know its design, like in the story with my mom, what happens?
Confusion, frustration, and sometimes significant consequences.
I think one of the greatest lies and confusions of our age deals with the question
of what is freedom. Have you ever thought in your life, what is real freedom?
When I ask students to define freedom, typically they'll say to me, freedom is when
you can do whatever you want to do, as long as nobody is telling you how to live
your life. If it feels good. Do it.
And you're free. Friends, that's not freedom.
Living according to whatever feels good is going to enslave you to your passions.
Real freedom is when we embrace God's design for our life, which is to love Him and
to love other people. That's why Jesus said in John chapter 3 that if we live
according to His design for our life, that we live in truth, our works will be made
known to the world.
Real freedom is not living according to whatever we think is right, but embracing
God's design for our life. Real freedom is when we live in light.
Bright. Light. Love.